خلينا شويه نتابع اجواء المباراه وخصوصا
من المغرب من الرباط وتابعوث
احتفالات مغربيه ولو محدوده بعد هزيمه
المنتخب المغربي وخروجه من المربع الذهبي
بعد خساره بهدفين لصفر في نصف نهائي كاس
العالم في قطر مع ذلك هي الجماهير
المغربيه تحتفل في تحيه لاسود الاطلس في
اول وصول لهم الى نصف النهائي
ان شاء الله
المغرب
ان شاء الله المنتخب ديالنا المغربي
[موسيقى]
اعتقد يعني اكثر المتفائلين ما كانش كي
توقعات سيناريو اا المنتخب المغربي دابا
في وصلنا نصف النهائي ايه مشكله الاصابات
وحتى التقدير في المباراه يعني كان بعد
تقديرات ولكن كتبقى انك خرجتي امام بطل
العالم
فخورين بعد المنتخب احنا فرحانين بزاف
المنتخب
ومن مصر ايضا متابعه لاصطاء مباراه المغرب
فرنسا في نصف النهائي نتعرف على اراء
الجمهور المصري والمغربي بعد اللقاء
[موسيقى]
هدف حدته انجاز وصلنا المربع الذهبي
وحنا حزنانين ولكن ديالك الكره فيها ربح
وفيها خساره والحمد لله هو الماتش كان
جميل جدا
كبير بس الحظ ما كانش معاهم وكفايه ان هم
وصلوا للمربع الذهبي
فريق محترم وفريق يعني كله نجوم بصراحه
شرفنا احنا كنا بنشجعوا كانه مصر